-My first guest is
a Golden Globe-nominated actress
who you can see
in the new series, "Solos,"
which is available on Amazon
Prime Video starting today.
Please welcome Constance Wu!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah! Oh, my.
Come on, welcome back!
♪♪
-Thank you.
Hi, how are you doing?
-I'm doing great.
Thank you so much.
It's great to see you again.
First of all,
I want to congratulate you
because, since the last time
you were on our show,
you had a beautiful baby.
So congratulations.
-Thank you!
Yeah. I had a beautiful
baby girl in August.
-Oh, my goodness.
Congratulations.
How is she doing?
How is it all going?
-Oh, she's the best.
She's the best.
She has a full head of hair.
You know, she has a blue butt.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh, yeah.
-Yeah, long nights,
or is she sleeping?
Everyone always asks that.
-You didn't ask me
about the blue butt, Jimmy.
I thought -- I thought
that you might be curious
about a baby with a blue butt.
-I didn't almost understand
what you said,
so I kind of skipped over it.
But...
Wait, she has a blue butt?
-Yes.
Her butt is the color blue.
-Okay.
Is it, like,
for printing purposes?
Like, they put her in the ink?
Why is her butt blue?
-Well, you know, I might need to
start thinking about,
you know, what I can
use it for,
her butt.
But no, actually,
there's this thing,
I had never heard of it before,
but it's called
a Mongolian spot.
And apparently, it happens
in a lot of Asian babies,
and my boyfriend and I
are both Asian.
And it's where your butt is blue
for like the first two years
of your life,
and then it just goes away.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know
if this is a bit or not.
I don't know if I believe this.
Is it a thing?
Has everyone heard of this?
[ Audience says "No" ]
-Yes!
-Oh, wait someone there
has heard of it.
-He had it.
-Oh, he had it?
-Well, I just think
it's a very special thing,
and it's not something that,
you know,
she gets to show off while
she's walking down the street.
So -- not that
she's walking yet.
But I thought I would just,
you know,
tell you about
her little blue butt.
It's very special.
-That is actually so cute.
Oh, my goodness.
And your boyfriend
is a musician.
So is he playing music
all the time for the baby?
-Yeah, he actually wrote a song
about her blue butt.
[ Laughter ]
So that will be
on his next album.
But yeah, he's a musician.
-Gonna be on the next album.
What's it like
dating a rock star?
Do you talk
about each other's music?
Do you, like, school each other
on different things?
-Well, I mean, you --
you probably know this life
because you were in that movie,
"Almost Famous."
-[ Scoffs ]
Please, hold your applause.
Hold your applause.
[ Laughter ]
You can't hear it, but they're
going nuts here right now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, stop. Oh, please.
This is embarrassing.
But thank you.
-Our life is like that movie
except, like, middle-aged.
-[ Laughs ] Okay.
All right.
Interesting, yeah.
But it's that rock lifestyle.
-Yeah.
And, you know, it's interesting
'cause he's an indie rocker.
His band is called Man Man,
and I am a musical theater nerd.
-Oh, my gosh. Wait a second.
You have to watch
the beginning of our show.
We just -- We launched
a new Broadway star.
[ Cheers and applause ]
David Poller.
Yeah. Have you ever heard
of David Poller?
[ Audience cheers ]
-I have now.
-Yeah, he's unbelievable.
Get ready.
Put your stock in David Poller.
I have a question for you,
because not only do you have
a brand-new beautiful baby girl
in your house,
but you also have
some other visitors.
Do you know
what I'm talking about?
-Yeah, I had some bees
visiting my house,
and I was like --
I did not know
where they were coming from.
So I kind of, like, followed
where these bees
were coming from.
And I saw them swarming around
this tiny little hole
in my wall
on the outside of my house.
So I investigated.
And it turns out that they had
built an entire hive
inside of the wall of my house.
-Look at this thing.
This is in the wall.
[ Audience oohs ]
-That's after they cut it out,
and that was inside.
-That's the most frightening
thing I've ever seen.
-It was, but you know
what's even scarier
is that, like, our bees are in
trouble in the world, right?
So we've got to save our bees.
So I was like,
"How do I save these bees,
but not have them in my house?"
So I got, like, a specialist
who had them humanely removed
and, like, found the scout bee
so they wouldn't come back.
Like, it was like
a whole process.
-Wow.
-Oh, my gosh. I'm sorry.
My baby just woke up
from her nap.
She's, like, screaming.
-I'll wrap this up.
I'll make it quick.
-No, no, it's fine.
She's with her dad.
It's cool.
-Are you sure?
You're like --
-It's like leaving your kid
with those guys
from "Almost Famous."
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
I want to make sure --
I want to get you
so you can go up
and take care of this baby
with this guy.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
I do want to talk about "Solos."
It's on Amazon Prime Video, and
it is basically monologues.
-Uh-huh.
-You're in a great company,
by the way.
Morgan Freeman, Helen Mirren,
Anthony Mackie.
Can you tell
everyone what this is?
-Yeah, they are literally solos.
Everybody episode is just
one actor, um, talking.
[ Baby screaming ]
Which, you know, I guess
could be a nightmare
to some people,
but it was real fun for us.
[ Laughter ]
-Your daughter just had
a good little cameo there.
That was a great -- I think
he's teaching her Led Zeppelin,
is what your boyfriend's
teaching her.
It sounds great.
Good. Good.
Get those lungs.
I love it, girl. I love it.
Please give her
a hug and a kiss from me.
And I want to show everyone
a clip.
Here's Constance Wu in "Solos."
Take a look at this.
-Now, this is wild.
So wait for it.
Yesterday afternoon, I went to
the birthday party
of a 2-year-old.
[ Chuckles ]
My friend's little girl.
I mean -- well, I mean,
our husbands work together.
I've only met her twice.
But it was a costume party,
obviously,
hence...et voilà!
I'm like an angel, basically.
You know, like, from the Bible.
I was checking that I didn't
smell sort of thing.
'Cause, like I said,
I haven't been home.
I actually think
I might still be drunk.
I'm Jenny, by the way.
I am great fun at parties.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Constance Wu!
"Solos" is available right now
on Amazon Prime Video.